since our first meeting in these formats
that happened one year ago the European
Union Armenia cooperation has advanced
very well with a particular focus on the
implementation of our agreement our
comprehensive and announced partnership
agreements we support the ongoing work
aiming at a comprehensive judicial
reform in Armenia in line with the
Romanian Constitution and with
international standards our Council
today our partnership Council today also
stressed the importance of continued
work towards implementing the Eastern
Partnership and in particular the
deliverables we have identified for next
year the 2020 deliverables including in
the field of rule of law governance and
the fight against corruption we also
discussed the peaceful resolution of the
nagorno-karabakh conflict the conflict
needs an early political settlement and
the European Union continues to fully
support the mediation efforts we also
reiterated today the European Union
commitment to support the normalization
of relations between Armenia and Turkey
we once again underscored the fire that
our comprehensive partnership is based
on shared values and a strong commitment
to uphold them I have also reflected on
the very big priority of judicial reform
in Armenia which takes up a very
important place in our domestic agenda
and underlined the importance of our
cooperation to this and we also
exchanged views on the prospects of
launching the Armenia is EU visa
liberalisation that this is a very
important issue in that it solidifies it
strengthens the nature of our
relationship by way of bringing people
together
you